hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
die absolut leckerste variante von bti
cap pick up ist würziges rinder
hackfleisch eingerollt in knackigen
music und getoppt mit joghurt und
tomatensoße ich will euch gar nicht
lange auf die folter spannen und zeigt
euch jetzt direkt die zutaten wir
benötigen rinder hackfleisch zwiebeln
paniermehl gewürze wie salz pfeffer
paprika flocken und basilikum
außerdem knoblauch und ein ei und wer
glaubt die zubereitung sie total
kompliziert aus sie ist so einfach ihr
müsst einfach nur alle zutaten in einer
schüssel miteinander verrühren
ich mache das ganz gerne so dass sich
alle zutaten bis auf das eine schüssel
geben und als allererstes miteinander
verknetet und zu guter letzt gebe ich
das ei mit hinzu und knetet das dann
alles noch mal richtig schön durch ihr
solltet allerdings schon darauf achten
dass die zwiebeln sehr sehr fein
geschnitten sind und die knoblauchzehe
ebenso aber die knoblauchzehe gebe ich
sowieso immer durch die knoblauchpresse
sobald dann sämtliche zutaten guten
miteinander verknotet sind und das
ebenso gibt ihr das ganz kurz an die
seite nun geht es weiter mit dem yoga
guide findet ihr in jedem arabischen
oder türkischen supermarkt und den
schneiden wir zuallererst der hälfte
einmal durch
die erste hälfte des yoga teigs nehmen
uns schon mal auf unsere arbeitsfläche
und ich fahre hier olivenöl mit
sonnenblumenöl ihr könntet auch oliven
und rapsöl verwenden und das vermisse
ich dann und gäbe dass mit einem pinsel
auf meinen you've got eick
sobald dann alles schön gestrichen wurde
geben wir schon mal einen teil des
fleischs auf die seite
verteilt also an der stelle eier fleisch
an der langen kanten und versuchte dann
ein wenig rund zurollen es muss auch
nicht perfekt sein und von der dicke
hermund haben sich circa drei zentimeter
im durchmesser ausgewählt ihr könnt
natürlich schauen die ihr das am
liebsten lügt
anschließend wird der ewv cup teig
zusammen mit dem fleisch nach oben hin
aufgerollt jetzt muss der strang nur
noch in kleine häppchen geschnitten
werden und dann verscharrt ihr so lange
weiter bis ihr kein fleisch mehr übrig
habt ihr solltet übrigens zwei dieser
strenge herausbekommen also doppelt so
viel wie ihr hier seht und jetzt zeige
ich euch wie ihr weiterfahrt begeben auf
ein mit backpapier ausgelegtes backblech
etwas von unserer öl mischung damit er
auch nichts kleben bleibt und verteilen
dann die häppchen darauf
die werden dann mit dem rest unserer öl
mischung gestrichen damit sie später
eine schöne farbe bekommen und nicht so
trocken sind und dann wandert das ganze
auch schon in den backofen gebacken wird
das ganze dann bei 200 grad ober und
unterhitze für 30 minuten für die
tomatensoße benötigen wir butter
tomatenmark wasser und getrocknete minze
außerdem brauchen wir zum ausgang in
joghurt ich habe hier den 3,5
prozentigen genommen für die schnelle
tomatensoße müssen wir ganz einfach die
butter in unserem topf erhitzen und am
besten bei mittlerer stufe denn ihr
wisst ja bei hoher hitze kann euch die
butter sehr schnell verbrennen
nun geben wir das tomatenmark mit hinzu
und rühren das so lange bis richtig
schöne röstaromen entstehen und das
ganze sich auch verbunden hat hinzu
kommt dann noch die getrocknete minze
wie könnt ihr euch direkt im supermarkt
mitnehmen wenn ihr den joker kauft und
die soße wird dann verdünnt mit dem
wasser so lange bis ihr eure wunsch
konsistenz erreicht habt somit ist die
tomatensoße auch schon fertig unsere big
box sind frisch aus dem ofen und sehen
so aus und jetzt zeige ich euch noch wie
ich das ganze anrichten würde
ihr seht also ich gebe auch mein teller
reichlich joghurt und tomatensoße gebe
dann noch ein paar aufgeschnittene
tomatenscheiben an die seite und
verteile darüber dann die betty kay jobs
basic camp ist einer meiner absoluten
lieblingsgerichte und ich bin so froh
dass ich mein rezept nun mit euch teilen
konnte und freue mich wenn ihr das ganze
nach macht lasst es euch denn gut
schmecken und schreib mir euer feedback
gerne in die kommentare
falls ihr nun weitere leckere gerichte
sehen möchtet dann kriegt gerne links
auf eines der beiden videos abonniert
mich über den button rechts gerne
kostenlos damit ja auch keines meiner
videos mehr verpasst bis zum nächsten
mal auf die skis kitchen